this video is sponsored by the
personalized soundscape app endl the
first 100 people to click the link in
the description will receive one week of
free audio experiences
born during a time when the expansion of
the universe and the increasing force of
dark energy had spread all the galaxy
groups so far apart they could no longer
be accessed or perceived from one
another ever again edward was a part of
a species who looked out at the universe
and saw what appeared to be an edge
leading to unending nothingness
the species that edward was a part of
referred to themselves as yamanus
they were deep descendants of an
evolutionary chain that began billions
of years prior on a once planet known as
earth earth having eventually ended like
all things in the universe do including
itself forced its inhabitants to spread
out onto subsidiary planets starting in
their solar system then eventually into
the greater parts of their galaxy which
was then known as the milky way
throughout this period the expansion of
the universe accelerated by dark energy
and the creation of new space-time
eventually caused the galaxy group that
the milky way was a part of to become
more and more tightly bound eventually
the milky way and its neighboring galaxy
andromeda would collide like two
star-crossed lovers bonding over their
shared increasing isolation in the
dimming universe
together they would birth the new
combined galaxy milk dromeda which would
become the new home for the surviving
interplanetary species once spurred from
earth
for millions of more years the story of
life in milk dramata as it always was
and always will would be written in
blood recurring missteps disasters and
setbacks would come in the form of
either partial self-destruction or
cosmic catastrophes
life would see major technological post
biology developments only to essentially
hit the reset button in some way or
another returning back near square one
throughout this period of evolutionary
trial and tribulation the rest of the
universe outside of milk dromeda would
continue to drift further and further
away at a certain point it would drift
so far the entirety of the observable
universe would pass the cosmological
horizon and become impossible for any
inhabitants of milk dromeda to ever
reach or interact with ever again no
matter how smart or technologically
advanced they became
they would become confined to their
final possible home and relatively soon
this home would close not only its doors
but its windows forever
ultimately as the universe would
continue to spread away further and
further not only would accessibility be
closed off but any and all traces of the
rest of the universe would no longer
even be able to be seen or known by milk
dromeda's inhabitants at all
from this moment on no outside light no
cosmic background radiation and no other
signs of the trillions of other galaxies
would ever or could ever be detected or
confirmed again
methods of science laws of physics
understood knowledge of the cosmos
technologies stories and medias all
would continue to be passed down from
generation to generation but as the
distance between the last actual
perception of the universe's prior state
fell further into the past and various
cosmic and evolutionary events detonated
into intellectual disorientations the
reality of the past portrayed in these
surviving artifacts lost much of their
truth
each preceding generation doubted more
and more the concepts of the universe's
past
edward born during this time of total
isolation from the rest of the truer
universe millions of years following the
last first-hand accounts of it found
himself along with the rest of the
yamanus looking out into the universe
and seeing a stagnant fixed edge
for them the universe was milk dromeda
and milk dromeda alone
shrouded in darkness
at an early age after his grandfather
bought him an astroscope when he was
seven years old edward developed a
strong passion for astronomy
together he and his grandfather would
always look up into the night sky and
bond over stories about what might exist
beyond the edge of the universe
edward's grandfather didn't have any
real scientific background or interest
but he was a very religious man who
loved ancient myths stories and
religious ideas about a domain of the
universe that extended past the
perceivable edge and held a heavenly
beyond
following childhood edward went to
academy for intercolonial law after
being pressured into it by his father
edward's grandfather however would
convince him by his third year to switch
to astronomy and follow his passion
which after some back and forth with his
father he would do along with switching
his second study to classics and ancient
history
following academy because of his
exceptional performance and work
displaying high-level understandings of
cosmological theory edward would receive
an offer for an incredible opportunity
to work at mount hale observatory for
hale cosmic laboratories which he would
accept
one thing that would almost immediately
set him apart as a cosmologist was how
much in the way he questioned the
contemporary scientific consensus about
the universe
at the time the universe was generally
agreed upon to be unmoving eternal
singular and confined within a
relatively small limit or edge that
could be observed outside of which it
was believed there was an eternal void
that went nowhere and contained nothing
but nothingness
however throughout his early career
edward would pull from his knowledge and
background in ancient mythology and
religion and would question these
currently agreed upon truths he
questioned if there was something beyond
the edge of the universe if there was a
beginning or end if there were other
dimensions if there was motion occurring
around and through it if there was more
edward was not alone in these
considerations but the majority of the
yamanos who considered or believed in
these sorts of ideas were primarily
associated with different religions
based around various ancient stories
medias and so on these religions had
developed and mutated out of the
portrayed cosmic spiritual possibilities
found within them
however unbeknownst to the yamanu's most
of these stories and sources were
primarily science fiction movies and
books made his entertainment throughout
milk drama's earlier history prior to
the final observations and interactions
with the truer universe
ironically some of what was believed by
these religious types was actually true
because the stories although
fictionalized and driven by thematic
messaging were based on a reality that
was in fact once real
and furthermore some of the ideas that
were believed to be religious weren't
references to anything spiritual or
otherworldly but rather were once real
science describing relatively accurate
conditions of the universe's past
at this point though ancient science and
ancient fiction had become so conflated
both equally absurd and inconceivable
they could no longer be distinguished
from one another and a weird singular
mixture of science fictional story and
religious dogma had formed from it all
all of which was mostly denied by modern
science
because edward involved these ideas at
all into his research even though
primarily from an agnostic perspective
early on in his career his reputation
would begin to tarnish and he would soon
become known as a sort of
pseudo-scientist eventually costing him
his dream job and ostracizing him for
most of the scientific community
[Music]
following this he would effectively be
forced to explore his theories
observations and research of the cosmos
and its relationship to the stories and
religions of ancient past on his own
he would never regain any serious
respect from the mainstream scientific
community but he would eventually garner
a small sort of underground subculture
following as an independent researcher
writer and lecturer
many individuals were attracted to his
theories and ideas because they melded
the scientific and spiritual in a way
that was rarely done with such nuance
and intellectual prowess
when he was 73 edward gave a lecture
that he typically gave as an overview of
his life's work one last time just
before he retired as a consequence of a
cerebral thrombosis debilitating his
cognitive function for the rest of his
short remaining life
to a small audience in a small
conference center he said
in my lifelong research of the cosmos
ancient mythology religion and other
echoes of the past it appears to me that
there are likely different major stages
of the universe that it progresses
through in time and in every one of
these stages it seems to rip out pages
from its own biography not merely rip
but shred beyond repair as if in an act
of self-repression it seems to bury the
memories of its past into its own
subconscious never to be retrieved again
if this is true for every conscious
inhabitant of the universe throughout
history including now they will remain
and develop increasingly impossible
mysteries about the universe's physics
and nature this is not because there
aren't answers but because the answers
are on those pages those pages long
since shredded in past time i believe
ideas and concepts about the universe
found in certain ancient stories
religions and literature are true not
all of them of course but some of them
i believe they at least point to some
remnants of potential truth once shown
on pieces of paper we no longer have in
our version of the cosmos autobiography
i believe there is an origin story to
this universe i don't believe it is just
this or just us
i believe there was a beginning which is
often referred to throughout ancient
stories and myths as either the big bang
or god i believe there is probably an
end as well
i believe there was once and likely
still is an entire other realm of the
universe beyond this one comprised of
other dimensions and other galaxies and
other things we can't even begin to
fathom
however what i've also realized in my
research and contemplations is even if
all or any of this is true who is to say
that when those stories and ideas first
formed there weren't already pages
ripped out
in the same way we cannot access proof
of the beginning of the universe or any
of the rest of the universe's trillions
of galaxies worth of a story if there is
any would it not likely be the case that
those who wrote tale of these phenomena
were also unable to reach parts of the
universe parts that would have explained
to them what they were missing
why and how things came from something
or nothing what and how made the first
something and ultimately where it all
goes and what it's all for if we could
not know now what they could know then
what could they not know then that could
have been known before them
i believe all intelligent beings have
and are continually being pushed away
from truth with an expansion of the
universe
that is why truth changes over time it
has never and can never be capital t
truth following some first moment at the
base of the universe forever thereafter
it is merely the truth of the time
billions of years ago conscious beings
were incapable of knowing precisely what
they were inside of how far back it went
and how many more of it there may have
been
just like how today
neither can we
we simply don't have enough of the pages
for this story to make sense
possibly no one ever has
and no one ever will
[Music]
this video was sponsored by
endl
life is constant ups and downs both
inside and out between the frantic
nature and happenings of day-to-day life
and the fluctuating storm of chemicals
inside the mind we are so often at
battle in defense of our mental state
there are many things that can help
assist in the process of combating this
and better maintaining self-regulation
but one that is often overlooked but is
no less extremely important is sound
the soundscape app endl recognizes this
that sound impacts well-being
backed by neuroscience patented
technology endl uses ai to react to
input data related to the time of day
the weather your heart rate location and
intention all to provide personalized
soundscape audio experiences that adapt
to your immediate circumstances unique
lifestyle as well as circadian and
ultradian rhythms ultimately helping you
better control and synchronize your
state of mind
we all know the importance of keeping a
soundtrack playing during certain
moments of the day and life in general
most of us listen to music throughout
the day but this neglects any sort of
focused efforts on calibrating the right
sound patterns melodies and tones to the
right moods at the right time with the
right subtlety not overpowering and not
knocking you off course into a worse
mental state whether it's to help boost
concentration while in workflow calm
down and relax in between or outside of
work or ease into sleep at the end of
the day endle provides beautiful
personalized soundscapes that do just
that ensuring that at all times in all
moods and all external conditions what
you listen to matches best to what you
want to feel
if you're interested you can sign up
using the link in the description the
first 100 people to use the link will
also receive one week of free audio
experiences
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video
[Music]
[Music]
you